what's up guys I hope you're having a
great holiday season since my last video
poll I've been practicing how to make
the magic ball and also the mini magic
balls so I can come up with a tutorial
after I made the mini magic ball I
wanted to make it a little bit larger so
I try it with larger paper but then I
want it to go a little bit larger than
this one so I take two pieces of paper
together to get this one and then I said
you know what I might as well give
myself a challenge so I taped together
24 pieces of paper to make this super
jumbo giant mega magic mini ball I
filmed myself doing it and then I posted
in the community section on my channel
to see if people wanted to see it and
just about all the comments said that
they wanted to see how I made it so I'm
going to show you a time-lapse video of
me making it then after seeing the
process of how long it takes if you
still want to see me make a tutorial for
it leave a comment below and give this
video a thumbs up also I'm not gonna say
how long it took me but if you guess and
post your answer down in the comments
below and you come close I'll post that
answer in the next video thanks for
watching I hope you guys enjoy it
[Music]
[Music]
oh well it's all done
I just gotta break it in now check it
out just like the third you a size mini
ball you press it down into a flat shape
and then turn it inside out like a
flower and you can flip it over and you
see it's a little bit lighter Lila what
do you think of the magic ball do you
like it what about this one you like
this one better there you go it's a new
scratching ball thanks for watching guys
and be sure to click on the button right
on Lila's face in order to subscribe all
right say bye Leela go giant mega mini
mega magic mini ball mega mega mega
magic mega mini magical